thanks Alex thanks for the organizers
and it's been a great uh pleasure to be
here for this Workshop so I'm Grant
cheneyback I'm going to talk about joint
work with the grad student nor Burrell
on relaxing common belief in social
networks
to motivate it and relate it to some of
the things we've been talking about so
it's part of a larger project that I
have in mind of talking about beliefs
about beliefs so these are not it's kind
of hard to change people's beliefs but
maybe easier to change their minds about
what other people believe
when forming them so one aspect of
beliefs about beliefs would be kind of
common knowledge which we'll Define more
rigorously but it's kind of what you
kind of think the community knows
um this is useful in coordination on
networks uh and you might do this for
social norms uh for revolt games and for
social learning with externalities so a
lot of the talks we've defined social
learning and you wanted to agree with
the ground truth in reality you can
complexify these models a little bit and
say that they would like to agree with
the ground truth but maybe also like to
agree with their friends uh maybe the
ground truth is sometimes not revealed
as it often isn't and a lot of the
controversies of our days we just move
on but at least if you agree with the
majority you have friends so butter May
kill you more than margarine but all
your friends may look down on you if you
uh if you eat margarine which is
synthetic instead of butter and maybe
you just want to be uh liked by your
friends more than you're worried about
cardiac arrest
um
also sometimes with social learning
there's there's kind of these uh these
Network effects if you want to agree
with your neighbors okay so that's kind
of coordination on on networks which
this is part of another key motivation
of this talk is everyone knows that
everyone knows that which is a kind of
funny phrase because when you say
everyone knows that you definitely don't
mean that everyone knows that because
otherwise you didn't need to say that
everyone knows that the reason you said
that everyone knows that is because they
didn't know that
right so there's this idea of common
belief of everybody knows that but in
fact not everybody knows that
so I'm going to set up uh some
background and uh the work before us and
some kind of theoretical ways to think
about this uh common belief that we're
talking about which we find is factional
belief then I'm going to apply it to a
Revolt game and it will take an
algorithmic perspective and what's going
to come out of this algorithmic
perspective is a nice kind of result uh
that the kind of community structure
doesn't seem to matter for these things
which is very disappointing to me the
community structure doesn't matter which
is disappointing because I like studying
Community structures but sad
um and then I'll if there's time we'll
show some computational experiments then
talk about some future directions and a
key kind of point of this talk is to
hopefully get people interested in
beliefs about beliefs and relaxing
common belief and uh using this to to
study uh problems in the future
so part one uh
common knowledge and it's analogs so the
intuitive definition of common knowledge
is you know it's common knowledge if
everybody knows it and everybody knows
it everybody knows it and everybody
knows that everybody knows it and
everybody knows that everybody knows
that everybody knows that everyone knows
it and so on down infinitely I could
just fill the rest of my talk up just
with this definition
um
but it won't okay and this is very
important for everything that we study
uh if you you know teach undergraduates
and you teach them Game Theory you
always assume that the game has common
knowledge the perhaps are common
knowledge everybody knows the actions
all this stuff is common knowledge and
this common knowledge helps the agents
to coordinate say on an equilibrium
without common knowledge you have no
equilibrium which is a sort of
coordination even if the agents are
competing against each other
of
one of the first people to kind of write
this down and study rigorously was amen
and he showed that common knowledge
implies that agents can't actually agree
to disagree it's kind of a funky
two-page result that agents so you can't
actually so in in theory if we're
rational and we have the same priorities
we should not be able to disagree on
while on on anything
of course kind of
the weirdness of this result and other
things I
make it desirable to kind of relax
certain aspects of common knowledge this
infinite regression aspect seems a
little weird at first a little
unrealistic and so we may want to try to
relax that and uh people have done that
but you know the people that say this it
you get funky things happen when you cut
off the reasoning at some finite level
just infinite reasoning uh I won't talk
about it much but Reuben season's email
game is an example and it seems kind of
a bad idea to truncate this reasoning
uh at infinite level however we could
try to relax the knowledge part so
knowledge is actually really uh strong
uh statement that you know something
kind of with a hundred percent uh
probability there's a lot of stuff we
think we know that isn't even true
um [Music]
not not for you but for me
um and so we could relax it to Common
belief right so proposition is common
belief when everyone believes with
probability P that it's true and
everyone believes it probably P that
everyone believes is probably p
that it's true and so on and so forth
down the line so it's not knowledge but
it's it's something that's believed with
some probability okay so that's
that's common belief
it is the same probability if you throw
uh I mean this is a definition by
Monitor and Summit and yeah it's the
same it's the same problem
and we'll see a justification for that
so um they show that basically the
previous results pulled kind of
approximately when you have this common
belief so you don't necessarily need to
agree on the payoffs in the game at
least as at least if you kind of believe
and agree enough on the the payoffs the
game okay and you know we're uh we're
gonna kind of trace this uh this paper
and some of the things that it does and
just kind of redo them in a slightly
different setting okay
so they should come knowledge kind of
generally if you generalize common
belief the results kind of approximately
hold and they also
um showed that you can reframe this
common knowledge and common belief in
terms of evident beliefs and if you use
evident beliefs which I'll Define in a
second uh it kind of gets rid of this
infinite hierarchical regression
um and this was implicit in ottman's
work but they made it explicit
so an Evidence
an event is evident knowledge if when it
occurs everyone knows that it occurred
okay so an example could be uh you know
we're in this room and I'm giving a talk
right everyone here knows that we're in
this room and I'm giving talk and so
that would be evidence knowledge the
fact that it's occurring means that we
know that it it has it has occurred so
that's evident knowledge now it could be
that it's actually not evident knowledge
because someone fell asleep
right so they're in here but they fell
asleep so they actually don't know that
it's occurring right because they fall
asleep they're not thinking about it
they don't know that everyone's here so
they fall asleep and uh so that you know
maybe we don't know it for sure but we
believe that Grant's engaging enough
speaker that nobody fell asleep even
though it's the penultimate Talk of the
conference thank you for being awake
um and so it's actually just an evident
belief right not evident knowledge
but we think we think it's true
so that's that's the idea of an evident
knowledge and evident belief okay uh now
I'm going to switch directions a tad bit
to uh Jay who who studied Revolt games
on social networks so now we're getting
to social networks
okay and he studied them from the
perspective of common knowledge okay so
agents on a network are trying to decide
if they want to participate in Revolt
and agents have a threshold and if they
know a certain number of people are
going to revolt then they'll go and
Revolt but if not they uh they would
like to stay home and not you know get
harassed by the authorities in the
streets
and um
so
you need kind of common knowledge that
thresholds are met otherwise you won't
go out into the streets we'll see an
example
sort of unappealing thing about his
model
is that we really require common
knowledge but it's very hard to write
down payoffs so that you need are you
going to work with common you write
common knowledge but can you do it with
common beliefs yeah well we're going to
relax that's this is unmotivating what
we're doing
with this so you're you're anticipating
you're asking the question I want you to
ask but uh we're gonna
yeah hold off for a little bit but yeah
um right like yeah so he
he has these payoffs so that it's kind
of infinitely bad to be out in the
streets
um without France right
um and you kind of uh take the limit and
we we don't have to do that because
we're going to be relaxing
to do this you you need this common
knowledge and it's a very local
phenomenon because you only know what's
happening in your neighborhood you don't
actually know anything for certain about
the people far away from you
and uh
finding these pockets of common
knowledge really reduces defined
increase and so here's an example so
there's four people in this graph they
would each like to revolt if four other
people or first
these two would like to roll the four
other people are voting and these two
would like to revolt even if only three
people are holding and the question is
is there a kind of equilibrium where
they go on the streets and the answer so
this is like a knowledge
an answer is having there's not and even
though everyone who liked durable
they don't know that these guys have
would like to roll to three people
enrolled they actually know that there's
three people on a Revolt this this poor
person and themselves but they don't
know that these four people are actually
going to revolve because they don't know
what this person's special that sort of
exists right so there's kind of everyone
has knowledge that everyone liked or
vote but it's not common knowledge
so what did they what do they believe
about the network structure here they
don't know the phone number yeah
um Okay so
I think but I'm not sure that in this
example maybe they know the two hop they
know how many neighbors
they know their neighborhood and they
know how many neighbors their neighbors
have but they don't know the connection
they know the connection between their
neighbors but not the people the
connection between people they don't see
I think that's what they have in mind
so I know this person has a neighbor but
I don't actually know what I'm used to
share a commentator if I'm this guy I
don't know what these two share a common
neighbor but I do know their names
but trade doesn't love
he doesn't have a formulas
um he has to do something I I uh what do
you do
uh what do we uh we assume we're gonna
assume the network is common knowledge I
mean you could you could relax that but
we don't
so uh now getting to Ben's home so these
Notions aren't so useful for analyzing
natural graphs okay so even a common
belief isn't so good because everyone
has to have common belief common belief
is a notion that everyone has it but if
we're on some like air that's running
random graph that sparse there's some
there's some guy out there
disconnected from everybody it's not he
doesn't have common belief of what's
going on and so kind of almost nothing
nothing kind of strong is going to be
common belief in the situation and in
the chase situation it's kind of only
worse even if you have like a narrative
training graph where each I just present
probably half you can't get
knowledge amongst more than two two long
end agents
because the largest Creek in the graph
is going to log in uh even though like
you should have a lot of knowledge on
such a social network intuitively you
kind of if you know half of the people
in the world you have a good beat on
what's going on
but knowledge is too strong
so our idea is to use what we call
factional belief and factional belief is
going to under under partial approximate
coordination
and so I'm a computer scientist so we
start with we stop our contributions
so we're going to formally Define this
idea of factional grief which we'll use
to analyze World Games we'll show an
algorithm and that the structural result
that um
only really needs the degree sequence of
networks and then uh we'll apply our
algorithm to simulated data to show
um
so formally formally modeling
knowledgeably okay so we have a state
space Omega okay and events e are
subsets of our state space
um we have a set of Agents I and for
every I there's a partition of this
state space of Pi and I right so he
learns which partition he's in
but uh doesn't learn anything else about
the state of the world okay and then
this is borrowed from uh
read newspaper uh we have this belief
operator so the belief of pli applied to
eat it says that agent I this is the
states of the world where agent I
believes that e happens will probably be
so this here this itself is actually an
event it's a subset of the state it's
the event that I P believes that event B
happens
foreign
state in the middle of there this is
Omega is this thing here this is our
partition of agent I and there's some
state but he doesn't learn the state he
only learns which participants
uh we're going to generalize this
evident definition now so an event is
going to be evident P mu belief if
um
yeah
when it happens
uh everybody or a not everybody a mu
fraction of Agents believe it happens
with probably
so not everyone believes it happens but
a certain fraction of the network
believes it happens that's probably
whatever happens so that's kind of our
thing so here we have an e and uh it
takes up kind of a large part of this uh
partitioned on its end and so kind of
for the sake of argument one event e
happens agent I kind of P believes it
happens and this has to be true for a
view fraction of the agent so it has to
fill up kind of the p-fraction partition
for a new fraction of H's
and so will it be
I'm just not passing into things from
the definition does it imply that
everybody knows who those agents are are
like no I won't imply if the information
structure is common knowledge it's not
that we can when an event could you go
back to the definition when an event
satisfies this definition you're saying
it's not the case despite common
knowledge of the information structure
that everybody can say ah it'll in fact
the for this event it'll be Mr one three
four whatever that will constitute the
refraction or well I think it has to be
right we have to know
uh so um
so we have an open question that's kind
of along these lines we don't know if
the like the Asians can switch at each
level but here like if the
you don't have to know which agents
because you will see that the event
could be like there exists so such and
so many agents and you know that they
exist because the because it's evident
event but you don't actually know which
ones are I see so their their identity
can be random yeah
right
foreign
[Music]
so an event f is going to be a common P
mu belief at Omega if there exists an
event e so we're trying to Define you
know when when some event f is have
believed at some state so
you know it's a Common Premium belief if
there exists event e that kind of Lies
somehow in between uh
Omega and F and is evident that's kind
of the intuition so this event e is a p
mu is an evident pmu belief
okay so when it happens uh mu fraction
of people if you believe it happens
the state belongs to E
and e is a subset not quite of f but of
um
of the event that a new fraction agency
believe that have happened
so uh that's the definition of this of
common belief at Omega and notice that
any event that is uh an evident pmu
belief is itself common pmu uh is itself
a Common Premium belief trivially when
it occurs because when it occurs uh
itself can serve as the as the e in this
definition here
any questions about are we getting lost
yeah
is something more General that can
happen like we want to be able to say
things like f is a we want to be able to
say things like f is a common belief at
Omega but the but how do we how would we
say that and the way the way you say
that is kind of there's this evident
belief contained in it right and then an
Omega is contained in that so when Omega
we know that e is occurring
or we we kind of pmu know that e is
occurring and because we know that P mu
e is occurring we know that the period
all that f with p mu know that f is
occurring as well
so that's the that's the idea
so you may perhaps this is related to
Ben's question but like the fraction in
point 1 and 0.3 can be different
agents the fraction is the same but the
identity of the agents can be different
yeah yeah
so this is kind of a sort of
illustration here so this is our event e
so we want to figure out that F which is
not super Illustrated but say this this
is uh kind of when I P believes f is
this here and we want to say that um
uh it's uh new
common belief so we have to replicate
this for new fraction agents and so you
need to find the set e that's in Omega
such that this e kind of fills out a box
from you the agents and that this e is a
subset of the the boxes that um each of
these agents these new agents kind of I
where each of these new agents on P
believe f
so if if you didn't like that come back
because we have another definition that
will turn out to be the same this one
might be uh more natural or less natural
depending on like so so we defined it
with evident beliefs we can also Define
it with this infinite hierarchy so at
the zeroth level we have f
and then at the first level we have the
event that a new fraction of Agents P
believe f
right so that's kind of the first level
the hierarchy and the next level of
hierarchy we have that a new fraction
agents P believe the first level of
hierarchy is occurring and so on and so
forth so this gives you an infinite
hierarchy of these uh beliefs and you
take the intersection of it okay so just
keep on kind of whittling down that new
fraction of so I
refraction of Agents P believe that a
new fraction of agency believe that a
refraction of agency we believe that F
right so as you go down the hierarchy
that's kind of what you get
and
the informal proposition is that this
event or this intersection events here
here is actually equal to the uh event f
is a common P mu belief so this tells
you exactly where f is a Common Premium
belief and more precisely
uh this uh e p mu of f is itself an
evident pmu belief right and it's a
subset of where a fraction of Agents uh
P believe that F occurs okay
and moreover this uh EP Nu of f contains
all other evident pmu beliefs which are
a subset of where new fraction agents
people be back
okay so this is kind of the the largest
evident belief and that's exactly why
it's kind of contained in this
intersection this this infinite
intersection
will kind of kill evident beliefs but it
will eventually shrink down until you
get to an evidently
so these are these are the same here I
guess when you say contains all other
evidence you mean the the noun the noun
phrase there P new belief is actually
being used to refer to an event
uh it contains all effect but but you're
using beliefs informally to refer to
events where those beliefs occur yeah uh
contains all other
events which are
uh yeah events which are evident pmu
beliefs and are a subset of
so now we're gonna we're gonna apply
this to study uh approximate
coordination on network Revolt games so
uh this is you can actually do the
network Revolt games without the fancy
philosophical uh preface but the fancy
feels awkward preface gives you a nice
idea for what's
going on okay so I see them
I was fast as I hoped
um so we have a graph uh that
um represents some social network and
the graph is common knowledge amongst
the agents and the Agents have a type
and their type is going to be either
Alpha new or something an x and x is a
collection of these Chi types and uh
I'll ruin this right so Alpha is kind of
always Revolt Alpha Nu is like never
revolt and Chi is kind of conditionally
revolting agents
uh the types are signed according to the
state of the world so some State gives
an IID kind of distribution over types
to each agent okay so each state has a
different distribution of types and we
have a prior p over the states so we
have a prior of the states each state is
just a distribution over types
each agent is going to commit to a pure
strategy that Maps a context which is
their type and their neighbors types
which is what they know to an action
which is Revolt or yield okay so they
look at their type they get to see their
neighbors types and then they have to
decide if they're going out in the
street or if they're staying at home
as I said the alpha agents should kind
of always Revolt their utilities are
defined as such the new agents should
never result never vote and these Kai J
agents should conditionally revolt and
each Chi J is associated with a
threshold pair PJ and muj such that an
agent of type Chi J should Revolt when
she believes that with probability at
least PJ
a at least and at least mu J fraction of
Agents were revolt
so she kind of has utility when a muj
fraction of Agents volts no utility or
negative utility when they don't and
these utilities are set so that they're
happy to revolt when they believe that
muja fraction of Agents will Revolt with
probability PJ
yes
the right so uh oh so each agent could
have multiple thresholds okay
um
you could create a model like that our
model is simple I I will be honest that
um I had to reread this paper it's been
a a little while covid got in the middle
of actually presenting this paper
um so I I know a fair bit about it and I
but I can't recall all the details of
everything we thought about at some
point we thought about that and I could
tell you if that kind of generalizes or
not I can't quite do that on the Fly
here but that's true yeah but I guess
that there is a coherent payoff where
you carry you need like if at least muj
fraction rules then you get a payoff you
you set up the utility to be zero one
yeah you can set up the utilities route
issue here
um whereas that you might have to work
harder to get the utilities and Alex's
situation
um no I think they're very natural
setups which will give his situation but
but you it's more it's actually not
completely obvious that there's any
well-defined tryouts that will make it
exactly like this
exactly but
so yeah I guess you get utility one from
revolting when you Jay if your friend to
hold and the utility like and then set
up the payoff yeah we write it down in
the paper it's not hard this is a this
is a trivial exercise
but uh
but you could but Alex's suggestions you
could do more complicated things where
if 80 I only have to be 20 certain that
80 of people Revolt but I need to be 80
certain that 20 of the people are
vulnerable and if either of those cases
are the case I might revolts but our
model uh that I'm presenting today does
not have that
so then instead of his agents commit to
a strategy nature determines the state
each agent is assigned a type according
to the distribution corresponding to the
state agents observe their context apply
their strategy choose an action if
they're passed
so an equilibrium agents maximizer X
anti their expected payoff given the
strategies of other agents and we're
going to be concerned with the largest
Revolt supported in equilibrium okay so
there might be multiple equilibrium
we're going to look at the one with the
largest rule
uh these are volts are supported by
symmetric equilibria and kind of natural
strategies
so uh we'll do a quick motivating model
which is going to be a on a grid so you
can think of the grid being embedded in
a Taurus so everyone has exactly four
neighbors okay and there's two types of
Agents there's the
um never volt agents and there's a
conditionally Revolt agents and the
conditional enrolled agents uh need to
believe with probably 40 percent that a
uh half of the agents are going to
revolve okay
there's no always Revolt agents in the
simple model and there's two equally
likely States there's an anti-government
state where uh 80 of the agents are
conditional revolters and there's a
pro-government state where 80 percent of
the agents are never opened
and well we'll also Define this idea of
a candidate agent which will come up
again later and these are can't these
are conditional types that have at least
two conditional type Neighbors
right so they have certain information
about the state of the world
temperature
now the proposition is that when our
grid is sufficiently large the event
that at least half the agents are
candidate agents
is an evident uh two-fifths one-half
belief to right and when it occurs
because that when it occurs it's a
common two-fifths one half belief that
supports a revolted size app
so and the claim is that
uh
the the event that at least half the
agents are candidate agents remember
Canada agent is a conditional revolter
with at least two neighbors that are
conditional revolters
uh is an evident uh two-fifths one-half
believed so that means that each agent
believes that half the each of the these
a there's
nothing agents uh believe that
half the agents
believe with that probably at least 40
percent that half the agents moved with
a produce 40 that half the agents are
candidate patients
so from sketch
um given their context
agents can compute the probability of
the state and they give them the context
and these candidate agents are going to
at least 80 believe that the state is a
okay non-candid agents are going to
assign some low probability to the state
a more than 80 and
[Music]
um
and they're going to fear that the the
probability of State B is kind of too
high and that there's not enough Canada
agents and they might stay home so we're
going to focus on the candidate agents
okay and the claim is that uh at least
half of the
at least
probably that at least half of the
agents or candidates given the status a
is at least half
and let's look why that is you can let X
I be the uh kind of indicator variable
that a particular agent is not a
candidate okay and then X is the sum of
the XIs so we want to know what's the
chance that uh you know this is the sum
of X is greater than a half we want that
to be small
right and we'd like to use kind of a
turn off type bound but um the problem
with doing that is that these uh
contacts are actually correlated right
my the context that I have is actually
related to the context that my neighbor
has because he's in my context and I'm
in his context right so we can't just go
full board with the turn off bound
uh and so for this so for example we'll
actually just use archives inequality uh
and you can see that because in
expectation this uh
an expectation this X in state a is less
than uh a fourth and so by markov's
inequality you can't have the the chance
that it's greater than a half has to be
less than half
so we have that if we're in state a
they're probably at least half the
agents are candidates is at least a half
okay and given the claim the candidate
agents believe uh that at least half the
agents or candidates are probably at
least two-fifths because they believe
they're in state a with 80 probability
and conditional means in state a they
believe
um with probably a half that uh half the
agents or candidates
yeah
and therefore the event that at least
half the Agents of candidates is a
evident two-fifths one-half belief okay
and Revolt here is a global they when
people are coordinating they don't care
about their coordination with their they
care about coordination with their
neighbors or no just just enough folks I
see yeah which is
did they I mean it's
it's debatable for certain contexts you
might care about your neighbors more
here you're just caring about police
Crackdown so you just need enough enough
people out there but another another you
know
for hold games is a stand-up for a more
General kind of coordination game and in
other games you might care might not be
quite the right model so the networks
that some of those networks not doing
much here right I mean it's me he's got
governing your observations whether you
have two friends who are who are you
know these candidate agents the
candidate this is generated by the
network structure but it could just as
well be some event that's just likely to
occur sufficiently often throughout a
population uh the network is a little
bit window dressing right
yeah I mean I didn't think so but uh I
mean a result kind of says that that's
true right because it's going to
determine I mean in the next uh two
minutes uh we'll see that uh that
um the degree doesn't uh doesn't matter
so let me um
I have uh
yeah
okay so I think I can I can do something
okay so so right so that that's a kind
of example and now we're going to do it
in a slightly more generalized case uh
very very quickly so we have three types
of Agents there's the number of voltage
always wilters and conditional filters
there's gonna be two states the
anti-government state and the
pro-government state
okay and uh the prior P contains all of
these things okay
our question that we want to be able to
answer is uh if we're given values Q
star and mu is it can we determine if
there is a result of size Nu star that's
supported with probably at least Q star
so I'm a computer scientist we write
this this is what we're given this is
what we want to say and the proposition
that this is actually NP hard so we're
not going to be able to do this
unfortunately
but uh we can do something really close
Okay so we're going to relax a little
bit and this Pryor makes things a little
bit more likely to happen I I you need a
slightly less uh shape Delta off your
belief and a little bit off the fraction
of agents and P plus makes it slightly
more
possible to happen and then we can
Define This Promise revolt and so here
given a mu star so given a fraction of
Agents we want to determine which of
three cases we're in one case is that um
is that almost always that fraction of
Agents is going to revolt another case
is basically if we're in state a but not
if we're in state B that fraction of
Agents is going to revolt and the last
case is that um
is that uh it's never the case that that
fraction of Agents is going to report
and what we need is this is a promise
problem so uh we're promised that we're
only in one of these cases we're in
exactly one of these cases in these
cases are written so that uh this each
case is just slightly larger than it
should be otherwise they're kind of
going to overlap each other so if you're
on the boundary you're going to be in
two of these at the same time and if
you're in two of them at the same time
that we don't care what our algorithm
outputs okay so here's a here's a
picture
um so the pictures here so here is a new
fraction of Agents if we have a low
fraction of Agents then no matter what
state we're in uh we're going to have uh
we're gonna we're gonna with probability
near one we're going to have a Revolt of
that size again the x-axis is actually
the size of the rule which is a little
weird then there's another kind of uh
State here where if if you have a new
fraction of agent sets in this kind of
yellow bar here then as long as we're in
state a which happens with probably
State a then it's going to support or
volt to that size and then there's a
larger fraction that we just never have
that many agents okay and then what this
says here is that the lines are the
boundary is a little fuzzy so there's a
little fuzziness on the boundary for
right near the boundary you can't quite
say what's going to happen but uh for
the most part we're okay
and our our theorem says that this we
can solve
I'm going to go a little quick
at a high level and let me just kind of
overview the the algorithm so we have uh
we would like to report this excess
which is the size of the largest Revolt
supported in each state and expectation
and so first we start off with a set of
candidate States
so the candidate states are the states
where the fraction of agents that are
conditional are always a realtor is
greater than mu right so if we're trying
to get a Revolt of size greater than mu
and we don't have at least the
conditional levels or voltage of size mu
we're not going to obtain that right so
then there's kind of two for those three
cases here so in the first case there's
no candidate States so no State supports
a Revolt of of this size in which case
the always revolters Governor revolt and
the conditional Realtors will never
revolt and the second case every state
supports a Revolt of size mu and in this
case
um the conditional revolters can just
always revolt and the always or volters
can always revolt and that'll be an
equilibrium and the third case which is
a little trickier is the case where uh
State a is a candidate state but State B
is not right so if agents know they're
in state a they'd kind of like to revolt
but if they the conditional agents like
to vote but if they don't know they're
in state a they they may not and here
what you do
as you take the set of all contexts that
an agent can have and you say okay which
of these contexts allow the agent to
know that he's in state a with probably
at least P okay and then you get rid of
all the other contexts that don't allow
him to know that and you ask if I just
look at the context where there's P
knowledge that they're in state a
uh do I have a mu fraction of agents
that are that are in those contexts or
all those revolters and if I do then
um I can expect those people to revolt
in uh in in state a and if
we're they're just going to revolt and
if I don't then I then I uh
um then it's only going to be the always
or Walters right because even though if
everyone knew they were in stay day
they'd like to revolt they don't have
common knowledge that there is they
don't this new real common belief that
they're in state a
so that was uh should I go over that
slower was that a little fast people
understanding
using at this point so
um let me let me try this one more time
okay so if we're in
[Music]
um
there's two cases where uh there's one
case where we're just never gonna
because the conditional agents are never
gonna Revolt because it's never the case
that uh there's just not enough of them
and they're they know they're gonna go
and get pounced on the street and
they're just they're not interested okay
there's another case where they're
always going to revolt because there's
enough disaffected people of the
government even in a pro-government
state that they could all go out in the
street and they'll be fine and then
there's this third case where they don't
know what state they're in okay and in
that case uh if they knew what state
they were in they could they could
Revolt in the state a but they don't
know what state they're in right but
they have a hint of what state they're
in their context gives them a hint of
what state they're in right so the
question is they'll go and Revolt if
they believe they're in state a with
probability p
okay so what fraction of Agents P
believe that they're in state a
all those revolters they don't care but
the conditional Realtors they care so
some of these contexts that happens in
state a allow them to pee believe that
they're in state a and some of them
don't so you take all the contexts where
the agents P believe they're in state a
and you say okay we're going to add up
all those revolters and we're going to
add up the people that when they're in
state aid P believe they're in state a
and if that gives you a new fraction
then this group of people is kind of
stable and they can revolt and otherwise
they're not going to revolt okay it will
just be always
and that
um kind of I don't that that's the heart
of of the uh the algorithm and um and
that gives you this uh this kind of
diagram here so there's these there's
these blue guys here so if the if the
size is small enough then the always
revolters will Revolt but also the
people that even in state B saw one of
these uh
one of these uh um contexts that made
them believe they're in state a they'll
Revolt as well
right so you know they hey I we thought
the Revolution was on they're out in the
streets but it turns out they're just
going to get clobbered right so that's
the blue bars there's some fraction of
people that are always going to revolt
or
um yeah and then uh these agents this
blue here is that oh we're in state a
and when we're in state a there's a lot
more people that have these contacts
that they believe they're in state a and
so they can support a revolt and then
there's some people that are just going
to stay home because they didn't get a
strong enough signal that they're in the
Revolt state
and uh one last thing I'll mention is
that uh you know we have to do this song
and dance around these probabilities
that uh the the kind of noise that you
have
because you have to use this
concentration bounds there are pretty
happy concentration bounds you can get
these contacts overlap but not too much
and that's why we assume the degree was
small
and then things work out pretty well and
I didn't stress it in the theorem
statement but this Delta so Epsilon you
get to pick
any constant and Delta decreases
exponentially in N at least an N to the
one third so it's going down pretty fast
a little bit okay great all right so uh
we did larger volt you can also do
smallest Revolt we did the we said the
degree was limited but in fact you can
get rid of that if you have large degree
nodes they kind of they know what state
they're in anyhow and you can remove
them more or less from the analysis and
uh interesting uh you can deal with a
larger number of states I'm going to
skip the pretty pictures
uh and just uh kind of start wrapping up
so um talked a little bit oh I didn't
the thing about and Ben pointed this out
about
um in the punchline that uh
this algorithm and which uh context
you're in only depends on your degree it
doesn't depend on the network structure
at all and because of that uh whether or
not you Revolt only depends on your
degree and there's a little bit of of
interdependence that's wrapped up in
these concentration bounds that kind of
go to zero as the graph gets big uh but
for the most part it uh it doesn't
matter right and so kind of what started
off so I would like you know community
structure is inside is kind of important
for Cascades Dean talked about this uh
in his talk it would seem to be
important for like Norms we're motivated
by Norms here but somehow it doesn't
really impact our model
um though you might hope that
and I think there's future extensions
that it could impact where for example
information about States travels through
a net the network structure and so a
community could could matter a lot more
in most cases
um and so you know future work is to
develop those cases apply this to social
norms and other ideas applying it to
like in influence maximization and
advertising so you see like these videos
on YouTube that advertise to you and you
have no idea who else is seeing this ad
in the Super Bowl the cost per ad is
actually greater per person than a
normal ad and in part that's because
when you see an ad in Super Bowl you
know everyone else saw the ad2 and so
you could put these this kind of common
knowledge in exact marketing examples
um there's two technical questions this
is the one that uh Ben asked which is
related at least this is the new
fraction at each level the hierarchy
have to be the the same or or not
and let me skip the other one and just
uh thank you
maybe I can just hijack both Krishna is
setting up I want to say I think uh so
I've